there are a few video game developers
that have as much cachet with an
audience as jeff kaplan
hi everyone this is jeff from the
overwatch team jeff from the overwatch
team jeff from the overwatch team not
only was he a vice president at blizzard
and director of overwatch but kaplan was
also a figurehead for the community to
gather around whether it was to complain
to him about the latest meta and lambast
balance changes
or to turn him into memes one from the
one two the three what's up this is jeff
from the overwatch
teams and celebrate the festive season
for most
jeff kaplan was overwatch it makes sense
then
that his departure from blizzard shook
the community giving rise to questions
about the future of overwatch 2
and the franchise in its totality as
well as the development team behind it
along with the announcement that kaplan
was leaving came confirmation that
former assistant game director aaron
keller would be taking on directorial
responsibilities for the project
and the team by keller's own admission
kaplan is a tough act to follow
but he's anchoring himself to creating
the best possible overwatch sequel that
he and the team can make
the first thing that keller said is
something that will sound familiar if
you ever heard kaplan talk about
developing overwatch
making the sequel is a team project and
in fact
his role in the creation of the game
might not be as hands-on as you think
instead it's the many talented people at
blizzard that are forging the future of
the franchise together
jeff and myself there's a few ways to
look at the position but one of them is
is we do the least amount of things for
this game
we're not opening up the editor and
building characters
or animating them or building maps for
this game
that's everybody on this team and so
it i get that from the outside this this
can look alarming and this can look like
the the entire team just left or the
vision holder for this
game just left but that's it's not the
case the team is the one that's carrying
the torch forward and
they always have been the overwatch team
was started in 2013.
our senior leadership group they're all
original members
of that team we have so many people that
started this project that are still
there and then we have brought
so many other people on that are now
like
these incredibly impactful creative
members of the team
and all of us together are the ones that
are that are bringing this forward and
i'm just happy
that i'm able to play whatever role in
it that i can
naturally the big question around
keller's appointment is whether things
are going to change drastically
people tend to ascribe a vision around a
game to one person
in the case of overwatch that person was
jeff kaplan
so does keller have his own ideas that
he wants to implement
i was lucky enough to be in a role
previous to this
where i was really well connected and
aligned to what the vision
for both overwatch one and overwatch two
were coming into a position like i'm in
right now
um we're mid-cycle on overwatch too i
don't think it's right
for me to suddenly make a bunch of big
changes
to to either one of these games
um and and i think what's nice is
there aren't really huge changes that i
that i do want to make to either game
because i've been so involved in
in both of them among fans one point of
discussion is the pace at which
overwatch content and updates are
delivered next to games like fortnite
call of duty war zone apex legends and
other big multiplayer experiences
overwatch moves at a glacial pace
looking forward with the aforementioned
games as competition
are there plans to speed things up
according to keller
quality is the priority but blizzard
knows things need to be quicker
and it needs to hold on to content a
little less yeah one of the
the values that that blizzard has is
this commit to quality
um and we're always looking to make the
very
best version of anything that that we
make but i think that there can be a
tendency to
cling to that and maybe hold on to
pieces
of content or systems that we made
longer than we should
we are going to make a great game and we
are really committed
to making it as amazing as we possibly
can and the last thing we want to do
is to release it early before it's ready
but we recognize that it's something
that
players are waiting for and it's
something that's important to put out
there
so we are doing as much as we possibly
can to accelerate the development
process for it
i think that this is something that when
i start looking forward
um just personally on what i think we
ought to be doing in the future
it's really important for the game and
for the community for us to be
releasing as much as we possibly can for
the game
of course one of the ways popular modern
games keep people engaged is through
things like a battle pass
and almost weekly updates something that
wasn't the case for overwatch
as a result there's been some discussion
about overwatch 2 needing to behave more
like other live service games if only to
ensure that the player base stays
healthy
while keller didn't say whether the
seeker will have features that have
become commonplace in other live service
games
he did indicate that having a lot of
content is important
i i can't really speak to exactly what
will be in there whether this game's
going to have
a battle pass or not but i think i can
talk to our values a little bit because
um when we when we design anything at
blizzard we like to set up the the
values for the pillars for it and then
everything kind of derives
from from those particular values and
the values for
overwatch too is that we we want the
game to
to feel like it has a constant heartbeat
um
that there's um a lot of updates to the
game and that the community knows that
um that it's kind of our first priority
um moving forward so it's hard for me to
say like every live game is a little
different
whether the value is a live service
value i think our value
is to put as much time and resources as
we can
into updating the live game into making
it always feel
kind of like new and fresh and
substantial
talking about the new pve mode the
so-called second part of overwatch 2's
experience
keller said that this mode was important
for people that might not be as
dedicated to competitive gaming
but still have a lot of love for the
game world and characters
as a result is something that the
development team is committed to
supporting what i'm hoping
is that going forward overwatch 2 can be
that game
that is played by a much broader section
of the community
i want the game to be just as
competitive if not
more so on the pvp side we have a lot of
really exciting things that we're doing
to i think
kind of shake up the way pvp is played
to
innovate on what we've done um and to
bring
you know new new game modes and really
interesting ways of playing to the table
but at the same time we want this way
for these people that
just love this world and its heroes to
be able to play the game
as well and and to to come away with um
like a really
um special um story and a deeper
understanding of what that world is and
that's what
this other side of the game is that
we're building or the pvp side of
development is something that
i think is incredibly streamlined across
the team
and it is something that we're experts
at i recognize
that the other side of the game is
it's a big undertaking and there's more
to it than than building
um the pvp side of the game and i think
the game that we've talked about
is um it's a content based game when you
start talking about
progression systems especially deep
progression systems you need a lot of
content
in order to be able to deliver like a
really great experience for players to
to work through that we have a lot of
people
on our team that have worked on
a lot of different projects throughout
the industry and a lot of different
games in blizzard we have a lot of
people from the world of warcraft team
from the diablo team and even from the
starcraft team and i think
that we all recognize the type of game
that we're building
and we're building all of the right
systems and the right content
in order to make it um really really
engaging and fun for players
so um i agree with you it's a it's a big
ask but i think that we're
we're set up and we're approaching it
eyes wide open knowing what it what it
needs to
to deliver on that so what about
becoming aaron keller from the overwatch
team
kaplan was a public presence the subject
of memes goofs and guests
is that something that keller wants or
needs to be and what is it like to have
that expectation on him from the
community
it's important for us to to um
communicate with our community
i i can't speak to exactly what um
all of the updates were look like um or
what the the
the ways that we communicate are going
to be we're we're talking about
um several things right now that we're
going to be doing going forward
but i i'm not exactly sure what form all
of them are going to take
but yes i will be talking to to the
community
we have every intention of remaining in
communication
with our community what that looks like
whether that's always me or not
i think is probably best left as a
process
rather than a decision i i guess what i
mean by that is
i think jeff was a little uncomfortable
as as the person out in front of the
overwatch team it was his
value that as much of the spotlight
could could be um put on the team itself
he ended up kind of kind of becoming
more and more focused on
um over time and i don't think there's
anything wrong with that
i think it worked out well for us but it
doesn't have to be that way i don't
have to be the person that's always
communicating
our our thoughts and intentions if it
ends up happening that way
it it will end up happening that way but
it could also be other people on the
team that are taking up that mantle i
think
the value here is that we continue
communicating
with our community the value isn't that
it has to be me
doing it teams especially like a
creative team a game development team
they're very organic structures and
um they're they're entirely formed
around
the strengths and weaknesses and
personalities of everybody on that team
from
um the newest members of the team to
to some of the the most senior people on
the team
um and a lot of times what happens
when somebody leaves a team especially
somebody in a leadership role
is everyone expects the new person
to just jump in and do everything that
the that that the person
that their predecessor was doing so in a
very real sense
we have a jeff shaped hole on our team
right now
but i'm not jeff i'm not i don't have
all the same strengths and weaknesses
that jeff has i have a different
leadership style
than jeff has um and so i think
going forward um things will look a
little different
across the team things will look a
little different the way
in our communication style to the
community
and there's nothing wrong with that it's
very natural
for for something like that to happen
every game director
that i know i've worked with has a
slightly different focus
um jeff was a vice president in
at blizzard and his focus um was really
wide and
he was also incredibly capable
of handling a wide focus and looking at
at
not just the team but different parts of
the organization
my mandate and some of this is
self-imposed
um some of this is in conversations with
other people across the company the team
is to focus as much as possible
on overwatch as a game that's where i'm
going to be pouring
my creative energy and passion and time
building that it's so interesting too
because
i think you could see jeff's love for
the game
in everything that he did um and
i i just really hope that going forward
the the community realizes that
not just me but everyone else on the
team shares that
um you know we're like we're developers
at blizzard entertainment where
like highly valued in the industry and
we could
typically go and work anywhere we want
to
but this is what we're choosing to work
on because
this is the game that we all love
does this mean overwatch is back
yes we are
[Music]
thanks for watching this video about
overwatch 2's new game director aaron
keller
this is actually a shortened down
version of the full interview which you
can read on gamespot.com
make sure to check it out because
there's a lot more details about the
future of overwatch 2 to managing the
team
and charting the past for the future of
the franchise you can find me on twitter
tomorrhege and i'll see you next time
you